I don't know
repairing the Lakers apart
it was just part of one of these insane
games that you're watching him have in
probably the biggest stage he's ever
played on Iverson
against Tyronn Lue Baseline right he
backs up he fires two ball got it again
he's way too good yes we're up four we
can beat these guys he steps around Lou
and drove it seven straight points by
Iverson looked like he was dead in the
water I can't tell you what the feeling
was like I can't duplicate it I was in
the moment I just know he fell in front
of me I don't know how I even thought
about stepping over him like that I was
just playing basketball I remember I
looked at all the coaches and we'd all
kind of smile because we never seen
anybody do something like that before
and probably would never see somebody do
it again AI dropped 48 in game one he
seemed to be sending a message you're
not gonna break me I'm gonna break you